life is this massive endurance event
where if you try to be occasionally
great all the time you're gonna burn out
but if you keep going consistently good
you just keep moving forward you know
there's gonna be obstacles there's gonna
be speed bumps there's gonna be a
resistance there's gonna be hills but
just keep driving through it
consistently it's not always gonna be
fun it's gonna suck it's gonna hurt but
that builds endurance when you look back
over a period of time you think i
actually made some progress through this
because i was consistently good rather
than trying to be or look occasionally
great
nick welcome to the show thank you for
having me thank you for having me in the
bear performance podcast thank you for
having me
here hey good dude it goes it goes both
ways right now
how did you get on with your recent
marathon
oh dude it was great i ran uh a 2 48 11
2 hours 48 minutes 11 seconds
the goal was to run sub 250
um that's coming off of
so to get some context my first marathon
was in 2018. this was a three-hour 57
minute marathon full suffer fest
my second marathon a year later was four
hours 15 minutes i got worse
and i told people i'm just not a runner
it's never going to happen
and then i finally committed to and
stopped believing that and
after an ironman i said i want to run my
first
sub three hour marathon and i want to i
went through the process and journey and
trained for it
and i failed i ran three hours 24
minutes i realized it was a lot harder
than i thought
i wasn't respecting that time
i went back into another prep and i ran
a two hour 56 minute 27 second marathon
this was last january
and uh then i realized
what's holding me back the only thing
that's holding me back is me
so i said i'm going to run a sub 250 and
we did it we prepped we went through the
process went through the journey stacked
the bricks did the workouts showed up to
buffalo new york with all the confidence
in the world and
crossed that finish line two hours 48
minutes 11 seconds how'd it feel
i felt it's one of those things like you
i interviewed matthew mcconaughey a few
months ago
and he said nothing is unbelievable he
hates the word unbelievable
unbelievable it happened it happens it's
going to happen
so
whenever i cross like
a finish line this could be a finish
line that's actually
physically there or you know a goal that
i've set
when you cross it
looking back when you set that goal or
that objective and you go through the
process
if you have the confidence knowing
you're going to do it
you're going to do it you just need to
put in the work now
so when i cross the finish line i wasn't
like holy crap sub 250
it was
no i knew after mile 3 i was gonna do it
like you know how you're feeling that
early on in the race
so it was it felt really good because
there was a lot of weight on the
shoulders because i share my goals with
the entire
world or my audience for whoever's
watching i got to tell people months
before it happens this is what i'm going
to do
now i'm going to document and show you
how i'm going to get there
so then when
it's finally time for me to be tested
yeah there's a lot of weight on my
shoulder that i carry
but i think that pressure also provides
some power in
how i'm going to perform
race day
it's interesting thinking about what
happens when people
set themselves targets and they they
slowly build up success over time
because you're right saying that
something is unbelievable or you can't
believe that something happened when
that was the outcome that you were
working toward
that's actually what you meant to have
happen and it's the same thing with the
podcast or with the supplement company
or with whatever it is that you're doing
the growth the increase in sales the
increase in subscribers the impact that
you have
that's the thing that you were working
toward that shouldn't be unbelievable i
think you're right and words have power
um i i just think it's mindless
sometimes people say that it's
unbelievable what they actually mean is
it's impressive or that's something
that's that's a a
sizable accomplishment they don't mean
that it's unbelievable maybe
unbelievable for them in their position
at the moment but yeah i mean it was
unbelievable or at least unlikely for
you in 2018 when you run one hour slower
than you did only a few years later
well one of the things i like to say is
uh
it's around the word doubt
i think i think the word doubt is a very
powerful word because doubt is only
dangerous
when you start doubting yourself
my entire life like people have doubted
me
as they should like
there's nothing there was nothing there
is nothing special about me when i
started my business in 2012
people made fun of me they would laugh
and joke about like oh here's nick with
his bpn supplement company
and they would laugh and joke and they
all doubted me
my mentors professors
people i worked for like my bosses all
doubted me
and doubt is okay like anyone can doubt
you
but until
you start believing that doubt when you
start doubting yourself that's when it's
dangerous did you end up with a chip on
your shoulder because of that no
yeah that's that i thought that that
would be your answer and it seems
surprising so in the uk that would be
the sort of narrative where a lot of
people certainly some of my friends
that would be something they'd remember
for a long time you know the crossing
the finish line would be this is a
middle finger to all of the people that
doubted me or moving into a new office
for the supplement company or whatever
hitting a new milestone with subscribers
that would be there and i always wonder
about the usefulness of uh
retribution
as a motivating force because it can
power you to do a lot of pretty
impressive things
but i'm not convinced it's the
healthiest way to to move forward i
think sometimes people
just say that too like they say they
have a chip on the shoulder and that's
why they do the things they do because
they actually don't look
they don't take inventory and stock of
of what they're actually feeling and
experiencing and why they're doing
something is it because you have so much
passion and purpose behind what you're
doing because
for me
whether people are cheering me on or not
i'm going to keep doing exactly what i'm
doing because i love it like i have
passion and purpose behind it and i see
there's people that are benefiting from
it and it's impacting other people's
lives
maybe those people are
you know watching the youtube videos or
following the brand or maybe their
employees here where
they're actually working in the hq or
maybe it's
the sons and daughters of employees or
significant others of employees that are
impacted by the things that we do so
yeah like a chip on the shoulder has
never
that's never been my oomph it's never
been my my reason why it's because
i'm doing something that i love doing
with people that i love being surrounded
by
that's my goal in life like
man if i can do this the rest of my life
that's pretty freaking cool like i get
to do what i love to do with people i
love doing it with
sign me up and the marathon is the last
big thing before dad life right that is
the last race on the horizon and i had
to convince my wife to let me do that
one because
we knew we found out that we were
pregnant
when i was prepping for rocky raccoon
which is a 100 mile ultra marathon that
we did in february
and uh
i knew i wanted to run a sub 250
marathon now my goal with it was i
wanted to document the whole journey
and through the series the goal was that
someone should be able to watch our
marathon prep series and they should be
able to pr their next race like we
wanted to provide them the tools
knowledge and resources to pr their next
race whether that's their first
race ever or
their 10th marathon
and we felt a responsibility and
obligation to do that to the series
so i talked to my wife and i said i got
to do one more race we got to do this
series
and she said as long as it's before june
that's fine
so i found a race on may 29th buffalo
new york i told my coach jeff cunningham
i said we need to find a race
that has a flat and fast course profile
before june
let's do it he said buffalo new york
so knock that out and i have i mean as
we're recording this is june 9th
our baby's due july 8th
so we're just about four weeks away a
baby girl i cannot i cannot wait
you've got this go one more ethos thing
with the impending dad life coming up
you're gonna have to make a lot of
sacrifices in other areas of your life
and this is something i'm increasingly
interested in as guys my age i'm 34
you're
31 31. you know this is the period where
you start to think about other people
than yourself and i'm fascinated by
whether you've
thought about some of the discomfort
that you might go through in terms of
having to make sacrifices or sucking at
areas of your life that previously have
been real sources of meaning or
accomplishment or achievement for you
are you ready for that you're ready for
the fact that you're gonna have to think
about
something else except for
whatever's in front of you
i am ready for that chapter
i will say that
probably a year and a half ago
i wasn't ready for that chapter
and it's one of those things like uh
i mean once it became real once we got
pregnant once my wife you know became
pregnant and we knew all right we're
about nine months out
it wasn't like this flip switched in my
mind but the best way to describe it is
i run in the morning right
and those morning runs for me provide a
lot of solitude
and
it's that one time where i have
an hour hour and a half every day
it's dark out it's quiet i don't have my
phone there's no notifications my mind
is clear
it is some of the most powerful moments
of my day and i need that
more mentally than physically
and
what used to happen during those morning
runs is that solitude provided me
ideas for where to take the business how
to grow the team who needs hired who
needs fired what can we do from a
customer acquisition standpoint and
strategy to to scale and keep growing
and i i was filled my cup was filled
during those morning runs on how to grow
this business
and i am forever grateful for that but
what started happening once we got
pregnant was
those moments of solitude in the morning
started to evolve and transition and
what i used to start or what i started
thinking of was
how do i want to raise my daughter
what values and morals i hope she gains
from me how am i going to do this
how do i set her up for success and like
what does success look like is it
independence is it being entrepreneurial
is it being challenged and tested how
much do i let her fail how much do i not
let her fail it's all these things i was
asking myself in my morning runs
and that's where i started realizing
okay my priorities are now shifting my
mindset was like molding on these
morning runs of
i recognize and realize that this next
chapter of life is real it's coming
but my body and mind is almost prepared
it's like it's preparing me for it
and uh
i'm going in i'm not nervous at all
everyone asks are you nervous are you
scared no
i'm i'm super excited i know it's going
to be super challenging i know it's
going to be hard
but selfishly i also know i'm going to
grow so much through this experience
that
i expect and anticipate it's gonna make
me a better business owner it's gonna
make me a better leader it's gonna make
me a better friend
better husband like it should only
improve all aspects of my life are you
saying that having a child is a
self-development strategy
you know it's hard to say right now
because i still don't have a kid i'm
four weeks out i'll let you know in a
year yeah i'll let you know
i could look back at this podcast and
say dude i was wrong
but that's what i'm expecting
yeah
what do you think is going to be the
biggest challenge that you've got
the biggest challenge
um
i think it's going to be balancing
right now
i've become really good over the last
10 years
of adding more onto my plate
being able to delegate some of that but
also absorb a lot
i'm the type of person that i will
absorb
a lot of responsibilities and
obligations to keep things moving
forward
i will hire people to help me achieve
some of these things but
as a business owner as an entrepreneur
you learn how to
juggle and handle a lot of things right
i think one of the biggest challenges
for me and i've told my wife this
already
i recorded a podcast with steve
weatherford last week and
he told me
in life you got to make sure your
priorities align with your calendar
so it's one thing to say
i'm a family man i care about my wife i
care about my
my uh daughter i care about my business
i care about my employees
but look at your calendar does your
calendar reflect what your priorities
say are they aligned
and uh it's gonna be hard for me
and i'll navigate it somehow but
i'm gonna say my priorities are my wife
my daughter my business my fitness
but if i look at my calendar will it
reflect that yep and that's what's gonna
be challenging i know it's going to
because like i said
i've become really good at adding more
things on to my life
and absorbing them
rather than eliminating some that aren't
as important and focusing and hyper
focusing on on those select few there's
a book called 4000 weeks by oliver
berkman and it's about time management
and productivity and stuff like that and
he's got a concept in that you'd love
the book i think it would be a great
thing for you to read as you go through
this little difficult period
and he's got an idea that you need to
decide in advance what you're going to
suck at
when you undertake a particular uh
project having a baby is a 18-year
project ish
and uh i really like the idea of that
because
especially if you're a go-getter a lot
of the time
when you start to feel things that you
used to value in yourself drop away
the pain of that happening can take your
focus away from the thing that you said
was the priority right now
so i like the idea of deciding in
advance that fitness
maybe conditions going to drop a little
bit i'm probably not going to be able to
run as fast i'm not going to be as
mobile or as strong or as lean or as
whatever
but that's what i've decided i'm going
to suck at in order to
look after wife look after baby ensure
that business and employees and
everything else is sorted and then if
there's time for fitness fitness can
come in
and
a lot of the time when it looks at
planning forward i think people struggle
with realizing that it's just for now
it's not for forever so you know
powerlifters and bodybuilders understand
the concept of periodizing your training
right i have a very specific goal that
i'm trying to achieve over the next
however long and i'm going to adapt
everything that i do to facilitate that
one thing but when it comes to doing our
yearly plan
unless you're very very intentional
about what you've got coming up you just
think that this routine is going to be
your routine forever
and
looking at something like this and going
okay i know that sleep's going to suffer
diet's going to suffer maybe going to be
some stress interpersonally between me
and my friend i'm not going to be as
social like at all i'm going to have
time to see friends as much all that
stuff
those are the things that you're going
to suck at this period of that doesn't
mean i'm not going to have friends for
the rest of my life that doesn't mean
that i can never get back into fitness
but it does
the idea of sucking choosing something
that you're going to suck at means that
at least for the next acute period of
time
when that arises when the inevitable
discomfort of seeing condition drop off
or fitness drop off you go well yeah
this is a sign that i'm doing the thing
that i'm supposed to be doing in a way
like i i knew that this was the entry
price that i had to pay to be able to do
this i do like that words it is it is
now it is not forever
because i see this question this is the
response all the time in regards to this
hybrid athlete training
and uh and adding in races
so like for me when i started getting
into fitness it was putting on size and
strength and
me and my brother and my dad my dad we
put on size and strength
pretty well we're built for it
so i got strong i got big and then i
started running and i started losing
some of this size and the responses i
was getting from people were aren't you
afraid to lose
size and strength
and in the beginning i was i was trying
to avoid it but then when you realize
well in order for me to run
this race or this marathon at a certain
time or pace or a distance
something has to give
right something something has to give
and it goes back to
keep when you keep adding things onto
your life
when you look at almost like this this
tower
and like if i keep adding things onto my
life and they're not really stuck
they're just you're just stacking them
on top of each other eventually
something has to give
and when it gives that whole tower
falls so like that's kind of how i've
navigated this whole fitness space too
is
you know that there are seasons in life
where i'm putting emphasis and pride
priority on certain things right now i
want to focus on this race with that
will come a decrease in size and
strength that is okay
it is this temporary feeling for now but
it is not forever it doesn't have to be
forever so i really like that concept
and i i think more people if they got
used to that and comfortable with that
they could be a much more efficient at
their goals
in the present
well remember as well that the goal is
to be an effective fit healthy human
with a good robust social network and a
job you care about in 30 years time like
that's the goal
what you're doing right now is supposed
to facilitate that overall and that
means that you're going to go through
these ebbs and flows i mean i'm i'm
screaming this to myself right this is a
lesson that i very much need to learn i
think i think we all are yeah which is
why it resonated so much talking about
the hybrid athlete hybrid ceo future dad
thing at the moment
how do you avoid burnout so you've
spoken about the fact that you take on a
lot of responsibility you were somebody
that started the company on your own and
if you needed to learn how to program
because you couldn't afford a developer
you'd go and do that and if you needed
to do an all-nighter to pack supplements
you'd do that
how is it that you've transitioned from
a period where you just continue to add
more and more on top
to one where there's more balance and
where you're prepared to delegate
control and to relinquish and to bring
in other people and talent and stuff
like that because it's your baby right
it's your baby
and you're having to let that go you're
having to watch other people [ __ ] about
with your baby
i mean it has to be very intentional
like with bpn
i bootstrapped this thing
um do you ever take outside funding
for the first time we wrapped up a seed
round investment about three weeks ago
that was the first time we ever after
nearly a decade after a decade
you know and up until a decade
no debt on the business we never touched
a line of credit it was just we kept we
kept investing back into the brand i
didn't take any money out of the
business for the first five years
didn't put myself on payroll until 2017.
started the business 2012.
that adsense money baby gotta get that
youtube you got to keep me going hey man
that's that's what i did like from from
social media and making money on social
media and youtube i took all that money
and invested it back into the business
to keep it afloat
building a product-based business
and managing cash flow that is tough
it ain't easy
so um
yeah bootstrap the business
and uh i have reached
i will be honest i have reached many
times throughout the last 10 years
in a period of burnout
i and what does how does that manifest
for you
um
extreme fatigue
stress
exhausted
um the team can feel like creatively i
can't i can't think i can't breathe like
when i say burnout
maybe burnout isn't the best
term or word to use
um
i reach i reach periods where i
i can feel that i've done too much i've
taken on too much and i can pull back a
little bit
and kind of
refine reassess make a better plan but
you know it was me
my brother
my brother now is our coo
joe who you met our director of
operations
and john byers who's our warehouse
manager now
it was us up until 2018
because i had to be very intentional
with hiring
and i had to save a lot of that cash and
cash flow for inventory
2019
i had the first opportunity to hire
a media director jordan utter
and i learned a lot through jordan
because when i hired jordan i realized
i could offload and delegate a lot of my
responsibilities tasks and duties
and when i offloaded that it allowed me
to work on the business rather in the
business for a lot of things
so i learned a lot by hiring jordan how
did you know that he was the first
person you needed to hire
i tested i knew i needed to hire a
videographer and someone to handle media
and i tested about 10 other people
i would meet them on social media or
online
i'd interview them i'd fly them down i'd
test them for a video or two they would
stay with me in my house
and then
you did that with 10 people for 10
people for about a year and a half
i was very
intentional with it i believe in the
term
higher slow
fire fast
and uh i finally found jordan and he
just got it i could tell by the look and
the feel the video he understood me we
shared the same values moral morals
principles we could connect like he knew
storytelling
he wasn't just trying to
recreate what everyone else was
recreating and doing as a creative
he wanted to do his own thing and put
his own his own spin on it and i
respected that a lot
so
jordan joined the team i offered him a
full-time job
and for me that was scary you know it's
like this guy was moving from ohio
to texas
i was taking a a chance on jordan but he
was taking a chance on me as well
and i learned and realized the power of
being able to delegate
and uh
and and hand off some of my legos if you
will
and then after jordan it was okay i see
the power in that and what it's doing to
build the brand so i hired someone else
for the creative space trey trey freeman
is now our our vp of marketing
when i hired trey i realized all right
now i'm building this marketing and
media team
and i can now focus on building the
business in other areas this has given
me a lot more time to actually think and
not do
and from there it was just intentionally
adding more members onto the team
and the thing is like when we hire
i'm not hiring based off of where you
went to college or university or what
your gpa was or or what tests and
certifications you had deadlift
max deadlift number that it was not a
fitness thing you had to like fitness
but it was more so like if i met you
and you were a good person you could
hold a conversation you knew
you knew how to maintain relationships
you just were a good person
in the beginning of building the
business
i i wanted you on the team i didn't know
what you were going to do but i knew you
had to be on the team i want to build
this with people like you well it's a
lot easier to teach skills than it is to
teach traits right somebody comes in
with the correct rights and attributes
they have humor the good is a part of a
team they're resilient they've got a
growth mindset they're psychologically
stable
try and teach somebody those things
really really difficult try and teach
somebody you taught yourself everything
that you now need the people to come in
and do so you know that it's possible to
teach that but yeah i mean
the navy seal
that i had on the show not long ago this
guy was talking about how you for the
most part companies hire on skills but
fire on attributes
so when they're looking to bring
somebody in they do the credentialism
they look at the cv and where did you go
to school
what can you program in and such like
that but when they get released it's
because they didn't work well as a part
of a team or because they're humorless
or because they're unable to go above
and beyond or whatever it might be
mm-hmm okay so
why don't flip that in its head what i
presume that somebody that has the right
traits and attributes will be able to
acquire the skills that they need to be
able to do the job
and instead but what the reason for that
is because hr departments for the most
part are kind of just procedural
operational
like
churn machines right it's like the
uh fulfillment department that we just
saw in your factory it's like what is it
that needs to go into this box what's
the easiest way to systematize that
going into this box
whereas if you've got something that
you're building bit by bit you can
actually do it based on attributes it's
culture you know you're building culture
me and some of the team here recently
finished a book it was called uh no
rules rule
and it's by the the
the ceo of netflix
and
it's all about building culture within
your organization now netflix has gone
to some extremes right where
they hire based off of talent density
and they believe that if you hire based
off of talent density meaning
you're hiring very talented people and
when you bring very talented people into
an organization together
and that talent is dense
they're going to feed and grow off of
each other
i mean they're going to create systems
and infrastructure and ideas
that are unimaginable right like it's
it's this powerful force that is moving
forward
and when you hire talent density and you
have talent density in your organization
you can pull back on some of the
controls so again netflix they didn't
have a pto policy it was unlimited pgo
paid time off right
so they could take
two months off if they wanted
or expense reporting there was no really
any expense reporting or guidelines it
was spend the company money how you
would spend yours
and obviously it bit them in the ass a
few times and right
it failed the model
but overall
when you bring in talented people
with
the right traits good intentions good
intentions you don't have to control
them you don't have to micromanage them
and you have this amazing culture that
builds well think about how much more
scalable that is right you know if you
want to rote create a
uh this is how to be a netflix employee
dot doc
and people have to read that and imbibe
it and it it's sort of this very
bureaucratic top-down dictatorial thing
as opposed to it being social cultural
enforcement that you see from the people
that are around you well this is just
the way that things are done here this
is the one and obviously this can happen
in toxic workplaces as well on the
reverse have somebody that comes in
who's really really growth-minded and
great and everybody else is dragging
their feet so it can work both for and
against you but if you're intentional
with it it's so much more scalable
because you don't need to constantly be
watching everyone over the shoulder you
don't need to have as many rules and
procedures what a procedure like an
operational report is is basically an
external constraint to try and limit
people that don't get it
just innately what you're doing is
you're just you're trying to create this
set of guidelines and rules and
restrictions so that even an idiot can
do this so me my business partner i run
nightclubs i have done for a long time
we would operationalize
everything but this is because we were
working with 18 year olds they were
children one year ago right you know
they were in school not even in what we
would call college or like high school
two years ago so
it's the first time they've been in a
business like this they needed
everything laying out for them and over
time you'd see these you know 18 year
old party boys come in and they become
managers and by the time they got to 21
22 maybe they'd done a placement yeah
with us maybe we'd had them on full time
you'd just be completely hands off you
just said look here's a problem just go
you you know the sort of solution that
we're looking for you understand what it
is that we're trying to do
but especially when you've got a company
that
you're hiring individually
slowly
for a very specific intentional purpose
i think that you can afford i found out
that
for the first
i want to say it's for the first
like
200 hires at spacex
elon musk dealt with them personally
i feel like i heard he say he said he
still hires a lot of them i that
wouldn't surprise you in interviews and
hires tyler cowan just wrote a book
called talent and in that he he uses
this example the fact that
elon richest man on the planet was
involved personally
in the hiring of most of the people for
the first
half decade or more
of the business and very much maybe
still be now as well i mean i think it's
smart here's a
here's a clear example of where we found
some struggles in that
i mean i will say scaling of business is
hard
and and why it's so hard
it's not necessarily hard because you're
trying to acquire new customers or
figuring out where to spend your
marketing dollars
it is hiring the right people and
bringing the right people on the team
and uh
going back to controls
so a few months ago
you know we're growing we're adding
people into the team and we have this
company vehicle this company car it's
called the bpn truck it's wrapped in bpn
uh logos and it looks pretty cool
and someone on the team took this truck
out for a weekend to use for an event
and they brought it back and i went to
get in it monday
and it was a mess they were
empty cans all over the place wrappers
camera equipment was still in there it
wasn't cleaned out
and i got pretty angry so i created this
new system in this new dock where
if you wanted to use the vpn truck you
had to sign it out
you had to
do this this checklist of checking for
all these pieces almost if you go to
enterprise and you run a vehicle you go
through the checklist it was like that
and then it got to a point where no one
wanted to even use the vehicle anymore
because it was a pain in the ass yep
so i got rid of that and i was like
looking back what was i thinking i was
i took a situation where i could have
used that as a learning experience and
development
and i added these constraints
to micromanage people who i empower do
and make big decisions in the business
you don't trust them to
bring a truck back in a not [ __ ] state
it's ridiculous right it's like i
understand the compulsion though you
know it's it's
the reason for all of this bureaucracy
it's why people in companies like to do
this you know i mean
on the flip side of that as well there
are certain principles i think
especially in our personal lives
it doesn't seem very romantic or very
natural to kind of implement that but
ben bergeron uh the guy from cfne he's
got this rule i think it's 5 p.m
5 p.m he leaves
uh his gym it doesn't matter what's
happening apparently consistently
they're in a really important meeting
sometimes with people from outside of
the company and they're all sat around a
table and it's 4 58 and ben starts
packing his stuff up and the people that
work for ben know what's going on but
everybody else sort of doesn't and ben's
laptop's away and he's putting him in
the back he's still talking
moving away and then it's 4 59 and ben's
right guys i'm i'm off even if it's in
the middle of the most important meeting
so there's certain things certain
principles i think
that you can implement
in that way that provide very good guard
rails but i think that it's when you
begin to create a an entire enterprise
style check-in checkout system that that
stops being a principle
that is scalable and that people
understand like bring the truck back in
a good state
right make sure that there's always gas
in the tank like don't be an idiot with
it that's a good principle the entire
checklist that takes people 30 minutes
to fill in
is
somehow different
i had the opportunity to sit down with
uh ben francis yep jimmy
jim shark ceo
and uh he came into austin for a weekend
and
was able to talk to him and i learned
more from ben
spending a few hours from him that i've
learned
in a long time
and uh what he said a few really good
things but one of the things he said was
you know there there are
one of three things
is going to hold your business back from
growing
it might be one thing it might be two it
might be all three if it's all three
you're [ __ ] out of luck it's
product brand and people
if you have a crap product you're only
going to sell so much of it you're never
going to sell
enough to be an impactful company
brand
if your brand just isn't there if you
don't have a mission a story if there's
no depth to that brand it is shallow it
will die off it'll fizzle out
but what holds most businesses and
brands and companies back is the people
because as you grow and evolve
you're always hiring right and if you
don't develop those people and that that
is a responsibility of the business
owner entrepreneur managers and leaders
you have to be developing your team
constantly because as soon as you stop
developing them and helping them grow
in their role and under the next role
they're stagnant they die and what
happens when they're stagnant and they
die the business is stagnant and it dies
so there's those three things to always
be assessing a business by if you want
to keep pushing forward and growing if
you want to be an industry leader
you got to be good at all three of those
going back to how you're operating
personally one of your coaches says it's
better to be consistently good than
occasionally great and it seems like
consistency is one of the
things that you probably excel at
what are the
frameworks or supporting structures
that you have that help you to maintain
consistency
yeah you know i never
really realized that consistency was
a quality trait of mine
up until maybe
a year and a half ago
and it was jordan utter our media
director that said
to me nick you're one of the most
consistent
people i've ever met
made me think
yeah i guess i guess i am like pretty
consistent that is my competitive
advantage that is what i
i excel in
if i look back i'll take you back to
high school and then going into college
i was never the stud athlete i was never
this stud student i was very average
very average
you know when i was playing sports in in
middle school in high school i was never
starting
i didn't make varsity
in multiple of those sports i wanted to
play collegiate baseball i wanted to go
to the pros that just wasn't in my deck
of cards my brother who's three years
younger than me he was a stud
but i always showed up i always showed
up put in the work did what i had to do
and
for me i just couldn't get good enough
in those
two years that i needed to to excel to
go to that next level
and then when i got to college
i joined the army rotc program i knew i
was going to go into the army my plan
after the army was actually to be a
chicken farmer in central pennsylvania
that's where i thought i would be at 31
years old didn't think i'd be here
and uh
joined the army
started my business and
when i started the business in 2012
it was never
i need to make this much money i need to
get the business to this level by this
time
it was just this very patient approach
of
i'm just going to do this until it turns
into something
i'm just going to show up every single
day
day after day brick by brick
and
i really didn't see much traction i mean
i saw these small wins but when i got to
south korea with the army on a nine
month rotation
what happened was i told myself
i want to make ten thousand dollars a
month in revenue by the time i leave
south korea i'm gonna give myself nine
months to do this when i got there we
were doing two thousand dollars a month
in revenue
so we were doing about
25 between 20 and 25 000 a year in
revenue with bpn this was 2016.
and
my approach was
i'm going to try to learn at least one
new thing
every single day if i learn at least one
new thing every single day by the time i
leave south korea and come back to the
states
i'm going to have this toolbox of new
things that i learned
so that's what i did i didn't watch any
tv didn't watch any movies
didn't do any socializing
the military was my priority job but
when i got off of work it was
teaching myself how to develop websites
how to
design labels how to use photoshop how
to edit videos how to tell stories how
to how to build a brand what is a brand
all these aspects of building a business
and within 90 days of being in south
korea we went from 2 000 a month in
revenue to ten thousand dollars a month
in revenue
and what i realized then was
it was almost like this snowball was
slowly picking up
my consistency from the years leading up
to that point
have finally compounded
it's like investing in
the stock market or a business like you
invest at a certain point
and that money just slowly starts to
compound over time and it grows and
grows and grows
and you don't see it day after day you
don't look back and say like holy crap
look what i made yesterday or today or
tomorrow
it is look what i made over the last
five six seven ten years
and that's where i realized that
all i got to do is just keep showing up
and chipping away i'm not gonna
change the world i'm not gonna change my
business i'm not gonna change my life
overnight
but i bet you in 10 15 20 years
i can be somewhere where i'm really
happy and proud to be
and that just became a part of my life
consistency has just been
part of my life since then i'm i'm very
disciplined i know what i need to do
and i think most people do most people
know
what they need to do
from the time they wake up to the time
they go to sleep what do they need to do
every single day to get to where they
want to be
you think that's true i think i think i
think people if they really take
inventory of their thoughts and
priorities
they know what they have to do
but what people end up doing and i'll
tell you a story about this what people
end up doing is they look for the
shortcuts
i know what i have to do but it's going
to take me 10 years
how can i find a shortcut
when i was in college here's my story i
wanted to make money
right i wanted to make money because i
was tired of
over drafting my bank account i was
tired of having no money for supplements
like i was tired of being broke in
college
so what i did is i would email all of
these companies
these brands these companies these
marketing agencies in central
pennsylvania and out near pittsburgh
pennsylvania and i would say hey i will
i will paint your logo and i will wrap
my car
in in your branding and i will drive
around all over this college if you pay
me 100 bucks a month
i knew that wasn't the answer to get
rich and make money i knew that wasn't
the answer to to be successful but i
wanted a quick book
i could have invested that time into
studying
or or getting a job somewhere else or
doing anything but i was like how do i
make the fastest dollar
easiest of something i'm already doing
and i think a lot of people apply that
mindset to everything they do in life
they know what it's going to take to
train for this marathon they know what
it's going to take to get stronger in
the gym they know what it's going to
take to get this next job promotion or
build this business
i tell people on social media i tell
people through storytelling i don't
sugarcoat it like this is what it took
for me to get from point a to point b
it was really [ __ ] hard
to get to this point in business it was
really hard
but
i didn't do anything
extra special out of the ordinary i
don't have a secret key that unlocks
some door that has all the secrets of
building a business i was just very
consistent day in
day out i think that's the problem with
the narrative that we've got around
success at the moment especially reality
tv where people just get plucked out of
obscurity and then thrown to the top of
a mountain where two million people know
them and they've got a fast fashion deal
for a couple of million bucks a year
it what it teaches young people about
what
success consists of
is not that you're supposed to do
something consistently for a very very
long time that adds value until you
eventually reach success it's that
you're supposed to be part of this
like hunger games style lottery where
you get picked out of nowhere and then
gifted
a claim for no real reason you know
previously
success used to mean a thing and
accolade and acclaim and admiration and
fame
all of that
it existed as a byproduct of somebody
doing something that was worthy of famed
accolade and success and admiration
but we've decoupled fame from that now
you can get fame purely for its own sake
people desire fame
for the fact that they want to be famous
and well known not because it's a signal
that you have done something worthy of
being famous right like how many people
there's people that eat tons of food on
youtube and that's the way that they've
managed to get themselves into some like
super super super well known position
now
entertainment's entertainment and if
they've managed to find a niche then you
know more fool those of us that haven't
decided to do 10 000 calorie challenges
every day but
you can't say that that person adds the
same sort of value as an inventor or an
artist or a musician or somebody that is
building something slowly and
consistently over time and take that to
the nth degree love island is just
starting in the uk the new season of
that and that is literally people being
pulled out of obscurity and by the time
that they come out they will be the best
known most talked about people in the
entire country
but six weeks ago they were just
some hairdresser from the middle of
manchester so what's changed okay they
were in the right place at the right
time so what's the lesson that you take
from that
not that you're supposed to do something
very hard for a long period of time that
success is this
dice roll
that happens to select few people and
has basically no correlation with hard
work it's simply about being in the
right place at the right time
i also think it comes down to i mean to
each their own
but it's like how do you define success
do you define if you want to be well
known for i wanna i wanna leave a legacy
like i want my
my daughter
in 10 years to say
this is who my dad was this is what he
did this is how he changed lives this is
this is my dad
and
you know i spent some time with some of
the the guys that were on um
the bachelor
that whole series
and i had some good conversations with
some of those guys and they told me that
you know they went on the show
and it changed their life overnight they
were famous people wanted to know who
they were dating
what they were doing where they were
eating all this stuff about them
but he some of them told me that
the best way to describe it was it was
monopoly money
they had built this this following
overnight they had this exposure they
had this fame
but they couldn't monetize it it wasn't
success it was fame
again everyone defines success
differently
but like for me it's it's legacy it's
very fragile that sort of thing so i was
the first person through the door of
season one of love island in the uk so
i'd know the process from that and you
come off and
people are interested in surface level
stuff
but the difference between and the show
is significantly bigger now there is a
caveat that you know now it really does
propel you to sort of superstardom
but
the difference between the sort of
following and interest that i had
coming off the back of that reality tv
show and being on tv
an hour a night for a month
and
where i've got to now with the show
which has been nearly 500 episodes over
four years
is
night and day and even if you were to
say well you could go on love island now
give up the show go on love island now
win it get all of the accolade it's
still more fragile that person is still
in a worse place
than somebody that has built something
and the other thing as well is
what's strange about consistency
far more people are talented or
enthusiastic about something than they
are consistent
like i see people that take up a new
pursuit or sport and they find
i've got i'm pretty adept at this in the
early stages or that they've got tons
and tons of motivation because it's new
and there's novelty
but what about
18 months from now when you've done this
a million times and your talent's been
competed away by all of the other people
who are just as talented as you and are
now 18 months steep well
that's where consistency comes in and
the weird thing is that if you see the
world as lacking consistency
that has to be the thing that has to be
the point of highest leverage because
that's the weakness that most people
don't have it's like look you can
separate yourself from the pack so much
more easily by being consistent than be
by being talented or enthusiastic
there's this stat that i love about
podcasts uh percent of podcasts don't
make it past episode three and over the
ninety percent that do
90 don't make your past episode 20.
so by making 21 podcast episodes you're
in the top percent of all podcasters
ever in history consistency beats talent
and enthusiasm
i like tying the word endurance with
consistency
you can apply this to anything this is
not just endurance through through
training in sports but
if you look at it like how did i get to
a 248 marathon
i ran a lot of slow miles you know in
order to run faster you have to run
slower you have to build your aerobic
base and foundation that is running
below your max aerobic heart rate
these runs are pretty boring right like
you're putting out this low effort
because you're trying to train
aerobically so your body can utilize
oxygen efficiently
and you have to run a lot of miles
below your max aerobic heart rate
be very consistent and disciplined in
this in this space and it builds
endurance over time it allows you to run
faster and run longer
there's no shortcut to it you have to
log the miles it might take months
in my case took years
years of running slow miles consistently
day in day out in order to build
endurance endurance is also applied to
to life
right like
as you're going through life what is
going to happen you're going to have
obstacles you're going to have speed
bumps there's going to be resistance
i look at it almost in terms of going
up hills like
when i'm riding a bike or i'm running it
always feels like i'm either going up a
hill or i'm running or riding into a
headwind there are hidden headwinds and
hills everywhere
that's good that's a resistance it's
pushing back on you it's telling you
you're alive keep pushing through those
obstacles should be there
life is this massive endurance event
where as you start going this goes back
to consistently good rather than
occasionally great
if you try to be occasionally great all
the time you're gonna you're gonna burn
out you're gonna bonk you're just gonna
stop you have to sit there for 10
minutes
get your [ __ ] back together and then
pick up and keep going but if you keep
going consistently good you just keep
trucking along keep moving forward
and you know there's gonna be obstacles
there's gonna be speed bumps there's
gonna be a resistance there's gonna be
hills there's gonna be headwinds
all the time
but just keep driving through it
consistently it's not always gonna be
fun it's gonna suck you're gonna fail
it's gonna hurt it's probably pretty
uncomfortable majority of the time
you're probably gonna get some chaffage
between your legs that's just gonna
happen
but that builds endurance when you look
back over a period of time you think
huh
i actually made some progress through
this because i was consistently good
rather than trying to be or look
occasionally great
how do you deal with when
the suck comes then not in physical
training i'm talking about in life with
consistency you get up at 5am pretty
much every single day
i
when you've got business stress
youtube stress
family stress new baby on the way
competing for this time the internet's
watching you and every runner on the
planet hates you
why is it or what is it that you do
where do you go to on the days when you
wake up and it really really is
difficult when the suck comes
i'm gonna ask the question if not me
then then who
like i am
i am in complete control of where my
life is going and ends up we all are
and as soon as you accept that that no
one else is no one else cares as much
about your goals then you do and if
someone cares more about your goals for
you than you do
you're probably doing it for the wrong
reason or you don't care enough
so from the time i wake up to the time i
go to sleep i think
no one wants what i want as much as i do
and no one ever will and that's how it
should be
and i am directly responsible for what i
accomplish and don't accomplish
if i don't accomplish it i have to take
responsibility i'm accountable
that means i failed
my employees it means i failed my my
wife
my family
i failed and that comes down to me
so it's constantly
realizing that
i'm responsible
taking that responsibility owning that
responsibility i don't think enough
people do
that can add a lot of pressure on though
you know that can feel overwhelming the
this is on my shoulders the successes
are mine to bear the failures of mine to
bear
does that not
sometimes make you
feel overwhelmed all the time okay so
how do you deal with the overwhelm
a lot of it is
to be honest it's talking it out loud
sitting out with my wife and like
explaining
and it's not venting
venting and complaining is is a lot
different from just communicating
sometimes like it typically happens at
dinner or after dinner i let my wife
know like
what i'm experiencing
what i'm going through like
how can we find solutions for this and i
honestly have a really solid team here
at vpn
and sometimes i'll sit down with with my
vp of marketing
media director
cat
my brother like
anyone here in the business and i just
kind of say this is what's happening
right now i need some help
and they are always very quick to jump
in and offer solutions and help
i i
realized i
am a very
i have a very amazing opportunity with
amazing people surrounding me
and a few months ago we
recorded this documentary called more
than the miles
our team went on to leadville colorado
we did leadville 100 it was 100 mile
ultra marathon
and uh we we completed it as a team and
the one thing we kept saying out there
was you can go really fast alone
but you can go so much further together
so even though i
i feel that responsibility
i'm overwhelmed i'm stressed for what i
feel like is on my shoulders
and i want to make this very evident the
reality is it's not all on my shoulders
because my team my family my wife they
are bald in as much as i'm bought in
they
they weigh that burden of responsibility
almost as much as i do i don't ask them
to i never do
but when you surround yourself and you
bring really good people onto your team
in your life
they will
take that responsibility and
accountability and they will hold some
of that so that you don't have to hold
it all even though you feel like you are
they help out so much this is the
interesting point right so this is
precisely where i think a lot of people
get stuck
you spend a lot of time
crafting a life built around your
ability to get things done
as you progress through life
you start to
need the assistance of other people and
other people just
gravitate toward the stuff that you're
doing
then as the stakes become higher
you have to
realize that you need to rely on other
people but that's not what got you here
what got you here was relying on
yourself
so now you need a new skill set
you can't continue
to leverage
your time
you have to outsource you have to
delegate you have to ask for help you
have to relinquish control and it's that
that exact point i think
that is what's very interesting
how do people
let go of a strategy that they know was
effective for them in the past
they know that they were a solo ranger
that was able to get things done simply
by the sweat of the brow
and now the stakes are so high that they
can't continue to do that and if they
try it's going to be they're going to
get burned out
how is it that they get
from
solo ranger to somebody that now can
allow other people in
that can
open up that can be vulnerable that can
show weakness that can ask for help
that that i think is one of the most
important elements and i think it's
one of the
ceiling caps that a lot of people get to
when it comes to
their growth uh whether it be personally
in business
um emotionally spiritually as well
that the tools that got them here are
not the same ones that are going to get
you there the things that you did that
got you from naught to 75 are not what's
going to get you from 75 to 90 or from
90 to 95
you have to invite that in there's a
book
called what guy you hear
won't get you there
and we say it here all the time
once you finally invite that in and
recognize it
and it's it's
it's really hard to invite in
because you're saying
what took you from zero to 75
was great it was fun i'm pretty
comfortable with it i enjoy being in
here and operating there
we could operate here the rest of our
life and do really well
but we're just going to stay right there
or
do we want to
go all in
put all of our chips and risk it all and
bet on ourselves
and do we want to kind of i don't want
to say forget what we did from 0 to 75
but we now need to establish a new plan
to get from 75 to 100.
and once you invite that in and
recognize that that's where we're at
with bpn right now we say it all the
time we can't keep looking back on what
we did in the past we need to look at
what we're going to do in the future
jesse itzler says this one thing he says
he doesn't hang his hat on any of his
previous accomplishments
any of the businesses that he sold which
he sold for a lot of money the books
he's read the things he's done you will
never find him talking about that where
he's hung his hat on that
back in the day i sold this business for
this much money and that's who i am no
he's talking about what he's doing this
year and what he's doing in the future
because what got him to this point was
great
but what gets him to
phase two
won't work the same way
in business or in life we all have an
edge that edge is what makes us us
like bpn has an edge i have an edge you
gotta know your edge
and that edge will be with you from the
time you are born to the time you die
maintain that edge keep that edge moving
forward
because that that's what makes you you
that's what makes your brand your brand
that's why people followed you in the
first place that edge has to maintain
but something else has to change
to get from 75 to 100
the hardest part in life is
that usually comes down to people
are the right people in your life
that you need to be surrounding yourself
with
sometimes people will hold you back are
you are you
are you selecting people to be in your
life as your friends as your employees
as your co-workers as your mentors
that are helping you and allowing you to
grow and develop
or are they keeping you at 75
and 75 is stuck
or are you keeping yourself at 75 by not
letting anybody else in
i think that i see this a lot on the
internet especially with guys right you
know
we've got a very individualistic
atomized meritocracy as a society at the
moment you know and there is a little
bit of romanticism around the monk mode
solo ranger going and getting after it
himself or herself
but
i i do think that there are far more
people than admitted to themselves that
are scared
they're scared of the fact that
if they open this up this is uncharted
territory for them that they need to
have faith in other people and that
there is something safe familiar
reassuring about just doing it yourself
and about not not relying too much on
other people
you spoke there about
you know betting on yourself and
trusting your gut which i think is
the intuition thing is a big part of how
you make decisions where's that bravery
come from is that just something that's
innate in you do you ever have
self-doubt because a lot of people
smart people that like to read and sort
of cerebral and cognitively minded
they can talk themselves out of
something that every fiber of their
being is screaming at them to do
i think it comes from experience there's
been a lot of times
where i haven't trusted my gut and i've
tried to resort to something i've read
or heard someone else say or do
and i think as much as my gut is telling
me
to choose option a
all of my experience from other people
this guy that i know this girl that i've
come across this podcast i listen to
it's telling me to choose option b and
as soon as i commit to option b
it fails i think ah
i should have listened to my gut
over time it comes with reps you just
need to get more reps in it's okay like
fail
your entire life at things
failing is getting reps in
sometimes you're gonna make the right
choice sometimes you're gonna make the
wrong choice
it happens
but the more reps you get the more
comfortable knowing
just based off your gut feeling
intuition
what should i be doing and a lot of that
time it comes down to
making decisions based off your
foundational values and principles
i have learned over time that
if i make decisions based off of my
valuable values and principles and
morals
that is my compass that will always
point me in the right direction
and i know what that looks like i know
that feels like
i think it's a bigger
question and debate to open up of
a lot of people have never built their
life
on a foundation of values principles and
morals
and if you don't have that that
foundation built
what are you building off of get a build
off of something that is solid and if
it's not solid
it's just gonna crumble what are the
values and principles that you rely on
integrity
transparency with my team
um
having strong faith
being dependable
um
selfless service
some of those are just some of the
values
some of those i learned in the military
a lot of those i learned from
family growing up my mom
a lot of them i've learned through being
an entrepreneur business owner
and being responsible for other people
and you learn through that
when you're put in a leadership position
or you experience good and bad
leadership
you realize what people are looking for
what helps people move forward how how
does it help people in the mission
organization overall
accomplish something together
i think that that foundation is
absolutely essential and it's one of
those things like
you can't build your foundation off of
your mentors
or whoever you follow on social media or
your favorite person
it's going to be a really honest
conversation with yourself of
taking inventory in stock what are your
priorities what do you truly value like
what does your life look like
in five to ten years as success how do
you define success
you know like i think
that's one thing that a lot of people
misunderstand is like
success doesn't
it's not this one area of life like you
define success however you want maybe
you don't care about money and you want
to have a really strong family and
relationship maybe you do care about
money maybe you want to build a business
maybe you
maybe you just want to be loyal to the
people that are in your life like
success means something different to
everyone but you have to define it for
yourself because if you don't you're not
living for yourself
that's scary does this i think it's
aristotle who says um if a man knows not
where he goes no wind is favorable
and the point of that is if you don't
work out what success by your own
definition you can choose you can decide
whatever it is that you want success to
mean
but you have to choose right
and if you don't what you're doing is
you're retrofitting other people's
societies norms or the paths of least
resistance or the weird ways that you've
dealt with your previous traumas that's
what's defining the direction that you
go in in terms of success
this question i kept on asking people
when lockdown started in the uk was
what would have had to have happened by
the end of lockdown
for you to look back on lockdown and
consider it a success you can have
anything right everybody's locked in the
house yeah you can't fly around the
world and stuff but you've got we didn't
know how long but you ended up with like
six months
pick something what would it be do you
want to learn to handstand do you want
to develop a relationship with your mum
do you want to
build a new skill what is it pick
anything and i think that
looking at retrofitting
your view of success
based on what you want success to be in
your life that's the it really is the
only way to ensure that you're doing the
right thing because if you don't then
you're going to end up at a place in
life not only that you don't want to be
but you didn't even mean to get to
success also changes and evolves over a
lifetime
if i look back at what
for me was defined as success three
years ago
is now very different
for for my life right now and what i'm
planning for in the future
like a successful life for me now is
i'm i'm very happy that i i decided to
start building my business when i did
and spent the last 10 years of just
hammering down to build this thing
because
what i realized it's allowed me to do is
i can now be super present for my family
and my kids in the future
success for me like if i had to paint
you a picture of what success looks
like for me and
in 10 years from now
and my daughter's 10 years old maybe we
have some more kids
we are on
20 to 50 acres we're on a big property
with these big oak trees with this long
driveway
and uh we have animals on our property
we have gardens we have produce we have
chicken houses
and
you did end up becoming a chicken farmer
we'll see give me 10 years
give me 10 years
and uh
i'm still working to build something
whether that's bpn or another business
or i'm investing in businesses and i'm
i'm challenged every day in some sort of
business environment but i'm not working
a lot like i'm choosing my hours of when
i work do you want to dial that back
having spent 10 years of real nose
against grindstone stuff is that
something that over the next 10 years
that you're wanting to
spend less time on absolutely
because
with my kids and my family being built
out
i like for success for me i want to be a
very present father
i want to be actively involved
i don't want to be a helicopter parent
but i want to be facilitating
challenges and growth and opportunities
for my kids and
you know i had some on the podcast last
week uh matt burdeau
and he's the founder of
acton academy placer schools
and
he comes in and helps people build out
these private schools
that are very
unconventional they're very
entrepreneurial
growth driven
um
the the curriculum is kind of guided by
asking questions this is some tim
kennedy [ __ ] isn't it so matt
worked with tim to open the school here
in cedar park of course he did matt and
tim are really good friends you're going
to send your kids to tim's school and
come back and they're going to be
putting you in real naked chokes and
stuff at six years old i want to open my
own school
i want to open one of the acting schools
because
i see that's where i can get back that's
where i can impact
all that being said like that's where i
success for me is
i'm helping people grow and develop in
their life
and they're building the life they want
and that's from time kids are going to
school
maybe they're older
but just getting really involved in the
community that i'm surrounded by
and always being present there for mine
for my kids
and what makes me say that is there's a
a few months ago might have been a year
ago and i was listening to this podcast
and there's this guy telling the story
and he spent 25 years building this
business
and finally he sold that business he
sold that business for
hundreds of millions of dollars
and
i think he was like 55 years old
something like that
and uh when he sold the business he went
to his family he said
all right guys i'm done working we made
it we're gonna travel the world and all
this kid looked at him and said
we don't want to travel with you we
don't even know you
you've been gone for the last 25 years
of our life the last thing we want to do
is spend time with you
that for me is failure
that's what the opposite of success
looks like that is ultimate failure
how brilliant is it that
this period that we're in now
i i'm not a dad
yet not as far as i'm aware but i
i can't wait to be one i really really
can't wait to be a dad uh and when i
look back at you know my dad and how
hard he had to work to support me and my
mom as we were growing up
it was so restrictive compared with the
options that we have now and that's not
to say you know two parent
incomes and real living wages and stuff
they are difficult
but every time that i speak to a another
guy who's about my age who is family
oriented
all of us are thinking the same thing
it's like i can't wait to be there for
my kids i want to use all of the
very nerdy hours that i've spent on my
own stretching and listening to podcasts
or going on walks and hearing audio
books or reading or doing whatever
and i want to synthesize all of this
especially if you're a creator right you
know
thousands of hours that you've spent
planning scripting recording editing
uploading promoting videos and that's
been for people that you care about
right but they're not your genetic
lineage right they're not they're not
that
sense of you they're not pure legacy
and now we have this everybody that i
speak to about this has the same
approach
everyone david perrell one of my buddies
who's in austin he said the other day
as he
imagines more and more about becoming a
father which he isn't yet but is can't
wait to be as he imagines more and more
about it he realizes that a lot of what
he did in his 20s in his early 30s
was building a life that allowed him to
become the father that he wants to be
even though that wasn't the goal right
but by working hard by giving himself
freedom by making smart choices
he's
positioned himself in the place
to become the sort of father that he
wants to be
and that's
it seems like a very different
a much more intentional and deliberate
form of parenting
than pretty much anything that i've
heard before certainly you know if i was
to ask my dad about the way that he
planned his life it was very much just
do what you can
right to provide for the family
it didn't have this same degree of
intentionality to it because i don't
think that maybe the information was
there quite so much i also think that
parents having kids earlier
doesn't allow them to perhaps build you
know parents are having kids when they
not long ago were still kids
if you're a 20 year old parent well
think about all of the stuff that you've
learned almost everything that you value
in yourself in terms of the insights
you're going to pass on to your children
has been developed over the last 11
years
so i just think it's really cool it's a
really really awesome
time to think about families moving
forward and and what it's going to
facilitate in kids and what it means for
for parenting
yeah because i look back at
you know when i was little
my mom was a school teacher
my mom knew she was going to be teaching
in the school until she retired there
was no
early retirement
right so it's
i think we now have it's more accessible
we have more opportunities
to set ourselves up for success early on
in life
if you make that decision and choice in
your 20s and 30s
and that's exact exact way i see it like
i now
have
built this career i built this business
i built this life that allows me
because the work that i put in
allows me to be the father and husband i
am in the future
i think of all the things i've done
failed at accomplished wins losses
highs lows over the course of my life if
there's one thing
i'm very proud of it is
that and i say that now but
when i look back i'm very thankful and
grateful that i started when i did like
i said a few minutes ago because
i know what that's gonna allow me to do
in five six seven years from now
that's a really important lesson there's
no one that i speak to that's doing
something that's
started a blog or a sub stack or a
youtube channel or anything right a
business
that
says i wish i'd started later
and that doesn't matter how late they
started right
every single person is happy that they
started then or perhaps that they could
have done it earlier so that's a lesson
to anybody that hasn't yet or is
vacillating the sat on the fence about
what it whether it is that they should
or shouldn't do that
every single person that i've spoken to
about this is happy that they started
when they did or earlier
well i think one of my greatest
traits in 2012 was
that i was honestly stupid
i was i was ignorant to the risks that i
was taking
and uh well everyone else around me
had a paralysis by analysis
i mean i graduated with some kids who
were
they were geniuses they were smart they
were ivy league schools i i was not
getting into it ivy league school i
couldn't get into penn state university
i went to indiana university of
pennsylvania
in western pennsylvania near pittsburgh
i was not like this genius dude so i
think that
because i was so ignorant to the risks
that i was taking in 2012 when i thought
i'm gonna start the supplement company
all by myself and we're gonna see where
it gets to
i didn't know like what could happen i
didn't know how much money it was gonna
cost to get started i didn't know how
much money it was gonna take to maintain
and sustain i didn't know cash flow i
didn't understand finances
marketing branding nothing
but
i knew what i wanted to do i knew what i
loved
i was ignorant to everything else
that's what allowed me to get started
and sometimes it's all you need is
everyone's waiting for the right time
the right place the right money
i'm gonna i'm gonna start training for
this next next year i'm gonna build this
business in like in like three years
from now so that when you know the time
is right i can build this business and
make a lot of money in six months
good luck with that plan
just get started just just establish the
foothold in there and slowly start
building off of it once you establish
that foothold you can you can build
this is the best way to describe it so
like i talk about this dream in the
future of
this property on 20 to 50 acres having
this this farm with my kids and all this
kind of stuff
and i'm not the type of person who's
going to wait
10 years now to go to go buy that
property i'm actively right now looking
for property but that's because you know
that you live in austin so the property
is going to be five times as expensive
in ten years truth
true
but i want to buy that property now and
i want to start you know changing and i
want to add some train features and do
you know mike caju from working against
gravity
uh yeah yeah so him and a d have just
got something uh
two hours
west two hours east sorry of austin
dude it's so nice it's so gorgeous
similar to what you're talking about and
it's
oh man i went up there it's got its own
little lake
so you can go out boating and him and
his little boy go out and they fish off
this little
like a little like old wooden oh dude
it's spectacular they had a festival up
there a couple of weeks ago
it's outstanding like it's so perfect
it's so beautiful and you just think
well
why wouldn't you do that
what if that's the sort of thing that
you want to that you want to be able to
provide to your family like why wouldn't
you do that and you're right apart from
the
insane property prices in austin have
you ever read the book deep work by cal
newport yes
so
this is a
this is a clear example of uh
a lot of times we want to be busier we
want to be doing more i think hustle
culture is
like it's evil
what what can i constantly be doing to
gain the edge or get to the next level
when it's not necessarily productive
it's just busy
i think deep work by cal newport
is a very interesting read because it
almost forces you to
find
opportunities in areas of solitude
and presence
and
quietness and eliminate distractions and
just stop being busy just be present
because when you are
you're going to make up so much ground
in that time your mind is clear it is
thinking is firing it is optimized
again that's why i like running
but i know that
in the future when i am less busy i'm
more productive
that's when all my wisdom is gonna kind
of
start unfolding you can be present you
can think you can you can go deep
depth is something that we lack a lot of
the times and
i always say like you can you can judge
someone's depth if you go to convert if
you go to dinner with someone so you go
to dinner with someone for the first
time ever
and
the conversation is probably going to go
one of two ways
one it's all shallow it's all surface
level
how about that weather here like
how about that corona
virus stuff you know you're just talking
about every uber conversation you've
ever had oh my gosh
where should i eat around here what do
you recommend
some conversations stay there they stay
shallow and it's just
boring
it's just boring or you can go to dinner
with someone for the first time in your
life
and you're talking about some deep [ __ ]
like you are reaching
depth in that conversation those are the
conversations i don't want to end i want
to have that dinner a million times over
again with that person because we're
actually getting somewhere
and
sometimes people have never actually had
a deep conversation in their life
they live in the shallow they live in
just like the
shortness that's boring
i want to go deep
one of the things that
i think about when looking at the
business and the channel and stuff that
you've built is that
it probably inspires
a lot of people you know you think
ceo
supplement company massive growth
youtube channel
hybrid athlete following of fans that
genuinely seem to connect with you and
care would care about what it is that
you do it's a very
uh
envious lifestyle but
with a lot of people that are in
positions like that i think there's uh
prices that they pay
that very few other people see
so what's the price that you pay for
being you
the the price i'm currently paying right
now
i mean sometimes that that sacrifice and
that price changes
i would say right now the price that i'm
paying i had this conversation with my
wife last night
i feel like
i haven't been present
lately
because you go from
i mean the the list of things to do or
think about or
or meetings to have
they never
end right there's always something you
can be working on
and as your team grows
there's more people to be working with
in helping them
and uh i'd say the one thing that i
struggle with right now is
from 5 a.m
until
11 p.m
that is a jam-packed day
there's no let up
it's you know we're either creating and
filming content
i'm training um i'm meeting with the
team
we're trying to get in some wholesale
retail accounts right now we just
wrapped up the seed round investment
uh a few weeks ago
i think a lot of people think that my
full-time
job is to train
but i train like everyone else
i train at six a.m before going into
work and get in the office at 8 a.m
or i train after work at 5 6 pm
that's when i train when i'm at work
i'm working
the one thing that i can confidently say
right now is i struggle with being
present
it's something i'm working to solve and
fix
and building on systems and plans to
alleviate that hopefully before the baby
gets here
but uh
i also believe that sometimes in life
there are
necessary sprints
sometimes you have to sprint through
periods of time to get a lot of stuff
done
as long as that sprint has
you know time that where it opens up and
you can kind of decompress and
all right that was a tough sprint
this is what we accomplished this is
where we're going to sustain is how
we're going to improve but
sprints are going to happen in life and
business
you can't avoid it sometimes but i think
consciously being able to recognize and
tell yourself what your weaknesses are
or what you're struggling with at the
moment
it'd be a bigger issue
if
i was going non-stop through this sprint
and i didn't recognize that i wasn't
present all the time
but when my wife can either call me out
on it or i can tell my wife like i know
i'm not present right now and i don't
really like that i'm not really
proud of that right now but
i gotta get through this moment
i think it's
it it's very strange when you've got
the outcomes that occur due to you being
the hustle and grind
getting worked on person right from the
outside that's fantastic
but it can embed a habit where
in very subtle ways even when you think
that you're being present you're always
sort of just looking over the current
moment's shoulder to what's coming next
and
one of the big things that's come up
throughout this conversation is
periodizing right knowing that there's
there's an end date to this and a big
part of that is just being able to take
stock okay what happened what was good
wasn't good uh and another big part of
the themes that's come up is having
people around you that you can actually
have that conversation with because
trying to continuously continuously just
bootstrap your own introspection and
reflection and growth it's very very
difficult like you're not going to be
able to call yourself out on your own
[ __ ] and you're on blind spots
anywhere near as well as somebody else
that's going along with you so
yeah man i uh i'm really excited to see
what comes next for you you know what
one of the best things i've learned how
to do and
i recommend listeners uh
do to
kind of alleviate some of these issues
surrounding yourself with people
who are smarter than you in certain
areas of your life
hire people who are smarter and more
experienced than you
it will quickly humble you like the
the last couple people i've hired for
the bpn team
they have more experience
they're smarter than me in certain areas
of the business
but they have helped me grow so much
if you can find mentors if you can find
friends or people in your life
whether hiring them into your business
or just
you know running with them on a weekend
surrounding yourself with people who
have been there and done it who who
might be able to provide you some
valuable information and mentor you
that helps you grow so much and that has
been super beneficial in terms of
building a business building a team
in the hiring process
nick bear ladies and gentlemen if people
want to keep up to date with what it is
that you're doing where should they go
instagram is nickbear fitness
youtube just type in nick bear i have
almost 800 videos on there most of them
with my shirt off you're bound to see me
and then uh the podcast is the bear
performance podcast i appreciate you
thanks man thank you what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace